when I took my first steps into
journalism as a student I was seldom
seen without one of these a moleskin
notebook but it was always a slight
nuisance having to transcribe everything
afterwards and gradually I migrated
towards typing my notes straight into my
laptop now Apple and others want the
likes of me to trade in their laptop for
a tablet in the hope of reviving fading
iPad sales they're especially targeting
creative types who might use an iPad pro
because they draw for a living the shift
away from paper is a threat to moleskin
the Italian company whose black
leather-bound notebooks were used by the
likes of Ernest Hemingway and Pablo
Picasso they're trying to keep hold of
their customers before they go fully
digital and I've come up with this the
smart writing set it uses a camera built
into this pen to transcribe your notes
and drawings instantly onto a phone or
tablet microscopic markings on the note
move or help the pen track its exact
position and on your handset you can
change the color and thickness of your
etchings or you can happily amble around
the city writing into your pad and
uploaded to your phone later in the day
let's be clear it's got nowhere near the
functionality of an iPad pro and Apple
pencil but at 199 dollars it's a hell of
a lot cheaper the iPad pro starts at
$599 plus 99 for the pencil more skins
ambitions will barely tickle iPad sales
the whole company reported one hundred
and forty five million dollars in
revenue plus compare that with the
twenty three billion dollars worth of
iPads at Apple salt
neither the moleskin nor the iPad can
make up for a lack of artistic ability
so for the creatively challenged like me
the moleskin is probably going to be
sufficient for my note-taking
you